la una 45 hora local de este 7 de
febrero del tribunal supremo de
elecciones presentó el resultado con el
80% de las juntas y esto continúa
dándole el 17 por ciento a josé maría
figueres el candidato de liberación
nacional y le sigue el candidato del
progreso social democrático rodrigo
chávez con un 16.6 por ciento muy cerca
quedó el candidato del tercer lugar en
el es fabricio alvarado de nueva
república con un
14.93 por ciento sin embargo como ya lo
has dicho quienes irían a la segunda
ronda parece ser que sería figueres y el
economista chávez además importante
destacar en lo que decías en la
participación fue muy baja el
abstencionismo el más alto 40 por ciento
y esto fue un fenómeno que se registró
principalmente en las zonas costeras del
país siendo y también los costarricenses
eligieron la conformación de su nueva
asamblea legislativa le preguntó
entonces cómo quedaron las fuerzas allí
así es ya existen algunas proyecciones
la bancada más grande sería la del
partido liberación nacional del
candidato josé maría figueres con unos
19 diputados seguido estaría la fracción
del partido unidad social cristiana otro
partido tradicional con unos 11
diputados y el partido social
democrático del posible candidato a
segunda ronda rodrigo chávez sería el
que tendría unos 9 diputados además
nueva república tendría seis diputados
dentro de ellos estaría el candidato del
tercer lugar fabricio alvarado que ya
fue diputado también tendrían bancadas
importantes el partido frente amplio de
izquierda y el partido liberal
progresista